[موسيقى]
مجتمعنا ذكوري تربيه حل خاصه كان برشيد في
نظر البعض جيتهم صعيبه انه الطفله في عمر
العشرين داخله بالصعيب
تعرضت المشاكل وبرشا صعوبات يجون بابا
تخرج في الليل تنقل الحل لكن توه بابا
يقول لهم بنتي نحوش
انه بل خطيبي سليم يمشي القهوه يقولوا له
مرتك في المستقبل تخدم من حله من جبل
الجبل توا يمشيوا خشمه لهنا
[موسيقى]
هلا ابو بكر عمري 26 سنه اول امراه عربيه
نستخرج سم الحل باله صغيره خدمتها وحدي
بدايه كنت التحدي انا عندي حساسيه من حل
ومن ثم نحل ومن اي حاجه ينتجها النحل
بديت نسمع لسم من الحل والاكثر انه ماهوش
موجود في تونس ماهوش معروف برشا بشوي بشوي
كلمت خطيبي هيا نعملوا حاجه هكا في سمن
حلو
عملنا الماكينه هذه جربتها نجحت
[موسيقى]
حساسيه في سم النحل هو القرص انت كيفاش
تقرص روحك بنحل نحل
ممكن الفين
وثلاثين
اله استخراج سم النحل نخرجو النحل من
البيت يبقى نحل كيما هو بعد جمعه نعاودو
نحطو استخراج سم النحل ونعاودو
[موسيقى]
كان اول لقاء لي بالنحانه في مؤتمر نابل
2019 لكن خوف وفرحه في نفس الوقت ما نعرفش
الدواء هزيت الماكينه للكبار النحانين
اللي موجودين دكتور موسى دكتور احمد عبود
دكتوره خديجه ايضا هذا الجهاز البسيط الي
من خلاله هاله تمكنت من تصنيعه سيكون لها
النحل كي تستخدمهم مستقبلا في معالجه
الكثير من الامراض فلنتمنى لها التوفيق
والسداد
[موسيقى]
بنى مشروعي الدكتور مزاحم ما احلاها
الفرحه انه انا
متنمز على يد كبار المحاليل باقيه نقرا
وباقيه نتطور كل شهر وكل شهرين وكل سته
شهور نخرج ببرودوي جديد نخرج بفكره جديده
نخرج
نحب نتعدل المرحله اما نعالج به والا
نحولو
تحديت روحي وتحديت المجتمع واكثر حاجه
بقينا نتحدى في روحه خاطر كل مره ننجح
نزيد نتحدى روحي باش نوصل المخيط
كي نبدو باش نخدموا ماكينه سمن الحل في
الليل تتخدم الماكينه تتحط في اللين ونبدا
تيستي وما تريكس ونبدا بابا يبدا رجده
ومتهني على خاطره عنده امراه
انا فخوره اني كنت امراه ناجحه حسيت لهم
رسو
[موسيقى]
الحاجه اللي اكتشفتها في روحي على خاطر ثم
حاجات يعرفوه من الناس عليك وانت ما
تعرفهمش اني قويه في كل مره
انا وليت نتنقل في الزلمه والماكينه تتحط
في الظلمه والنقل انا نخاف من الحيوانات
الزاحفه
نبكي وما هبطتش به تنحل مني هذيك استثماري
[موسيقى]
توك نحكي مع رجال النحالين ندب ند ما عادش
نحكي
لا لا عملت ماكينه ونجبت في سم النحل
ومازلت باش نتطور في سم النحل
[موسيقى]
اذا ما نجمتش تطير اجري اذا ما نجمتش تجري
امشي اذا ما نشمتش تمشي ازحف المهم ما
تقفش وانا باقيه نعلي ونطير